сьогодні 1 вересня телеканал Рада веде
свій ефір з охтирки на Сумщині а сама
свято першого дзвоника є свідченням
продовження життя і накопичення знань
про Україну Про це заявив президент
Володимир Зеленський глава держави
привітав українців з Днем знань
цьогорічне 1 вересня дуже відрізняється
від 30 попередніх але все ж об'єднує в
собі десятки попередніх попередніх років
попередніх століть бит які були і битви
які тривають перемог які вислозали з рук
нашого народу і перемог які українці
здобували і тієї Перемоги яка
обов'язково буде
форма навчання в українських школах яке
розпочалося 1 вересня буде залежати від
кількох речей по-перше готовності школи
щодо безпеки тобто наявність у кротів
по-друге розташування школи та регіону і
по-третє бажання батьків які самі
обиратимуть піде дитину до школи чи
навчатиметься онлайн із майже 13 тисяч
діючих українських шкіл Близько трьох
тисяч закладів готові розпочати очне
навчання майже 4 тисячі навчальних
закладів будуть поєднувати як
дистанційний так і стаціонарне навчання
і понад 5,5 тисяч навчальних закладів
початкової та середньої освіти змушені
будуть давати дітям знання на відстані
остаточне рішення щодо форми навчання за
місцевими адміністраціями та
управліннями освіти
детальніше про організацію і про форму
навчання яка буде в даних умовах А нам
розповість міністр освіти та науки
України Сергій шкарли долучається до
нашого ефіру п Сергію наші вітання Вам і
все-таки зі святом першого дзвоника як
не як 1 вересня
Доброго дня дуже дякую Вам слава Україні
що канал Рада телемарафон завжди
опікується питанням освіти адже це
мабуть найголовніше те що про майбутнє
готовий до ваших запитанья пане Сергію
категорично з вами погоджується хочу
почути а від вас все-таки детальніше як
буде організована форма навчання як
педагоги викладатимуть свої дисципліни у
зоні за яким принципом даватимуть теми
як вони перевірятимуть як вони взагалі
організовуватимуть уроки
Дякую вам за запитання хочу трошки
поправити певний анонс не 3000 з
половиною шкіл готові до навчання
повноформатного навчання в нас на
сьогодні поза результатами комплексних
перевірок і ДСНС і закладів освіти і
місцевих адміністрацій в нас в цілому в
середньому 51% закладів освіти всіх
типів готовий до навчання в безпековій
ситуації в форматі
повного форматному режимі а саме школи
саме заклади загальної середньої освіти
це 59% закладів причому
3540 шкіл працюють в повноформатному
режимі 100%.
3870 шкіл працюють змішаному форматі які
передбачає як онлайн формат так і
повноформатне навчання на жаль
5497 шкіл ми будемо працювати виключно в
режимі онлайн
цей пов'язано як із наявності не
наявністю укриттів це пов'язано також із
розташуванням школи в небезпечній
Території дійсно приймає рішення саме
засновник саме голова
військово-цивільної адміністрації кожен
керівник громади визначає формат
навчання тієї того чи іншого закладу
освіти університети і коледжі автономні
Вони теж самостійно будуть визначати
заклади освіти але наголошували
наголошую безпека на першому місці для
неповнолітніх дітей думка батьків є
необхідною умовою для того щоб визначити
формат навчання відповідно до того як як
оголошено по школі Дякую вам пане
міністр про формат Я б хотів би запитати
дещо пізніше але оскільки 1 вересня
розмова з тема з якою ми почали розмову
а в скількох школах сьогодні власне
пролунав в тому чи іншому вигляді Перший
дзвоник відбулося Це свято є у вас
статистика
А ви знаєте пролунало
12906 шкіл які сьогодні готові до
навчання але пролунав бо декількох
форматах бо очному
[музика]
і в змішаному але я тішусь тим що майже
7400 шкіл які сьогодні
запустили в навіть в змішаному форматі
все одно проводили лінійки Я сьогодні
особисто сам був і вдячний президенту що
він знайшов час і відвідав школу в якій
які дійсно пролунав перший дзвіночок для
п'яти перших класів
для дітей першачків це дуже
особливе свято Я думаю що ви як міністр
який опікується освітою це прекрасно
розумієте А тепер от про те як в тому
числі і першачки навчатимуться тому що
Ви вже сказали які заклади готові але
тут важливий момент
є багато дітей на жаль за кордоном у нас
попередній годині була мама одразу двох
школярів яка розповіла що її діти
навчатимуться і за українською і за
польською програмою Чи є у вас
статистика скільки таких дітей
є серед українців які навчаються за
кордоном і як вони будуть повертатися до
українського навчання адже Таким чином
вони можуть інтегруватися в освітній і
соціальній е-е простір тієї країни де
вони вимушені перебувати
я вам дякую за запитання надзвичайно
актуальне ну перш за все Трошки
статистики в повноформатному режимі буде
навчатись
864,5 тисячі дітей яких батьки обрали і
до і повірили в школі і визначили ту
саме саме ту тезу яку ми формували
впродовж всього літа а саме повертайся
до навчання
1780 ні 1 млн 780 2 000 дітей буде
навчатися в виключно в онлайн форматі
так визначили батьки так визначили школи
так визначили територіальні громади і
засновники і 1 млн 252 000 буде
навчатися змішано тобто частина буде
уроків проходити в онлайн форматі
частину повноформатному форматі В мене є
дещо оптимізм стосовно тих дітей які
виїхали за межамитної території України
якщо на березень таких було 670 тисяч в
липні таких було 640 також дітей
шкільного віку які виїхали за межамитної
території України то вже на сьогодні
станом на 1 вересня ми маємо 492 тисячі
дітей які перебувають не в Україні але
при цьому обліковуються в українських
школах
У навчання мене не лякає оскільки якщо
дитина навчається Ну наприклад як ви
провели наприклад польській школі то в
цій польській школі завдячуючи моїм
колегам міністрам освіти країни
Європейського Союзу Великої сімки ще
багатьох країн світу ми на сьогодні
маємо від 3 до 5 годин виключно
уроків української мови історії України
і культури України для того щоб не
забували українські діти і для того щоб
в них була можливість повернутися до
нормального життя повернутись до України
або це буде або це шести шостий день
навчання в суботу Це виключно
український формат навчання в мене
стриманий оптимізм щодо повернення адже
на сьогодні який меседж Ми йдемо так і
буде адже на 15
вересня ми розраховуємо що вже 71%
українських шкіл буде по безпековій
ситуації готовий до повноформатного
навчання зрозуміло Дякуємо вам Дякуємо і
ми сподіваємося і пам'ятаємо що найвища
цінність теж Збереження життя та
здоров'я але попри воєнний стан попри
війну сподіваємося що освіта в нашій
країні буде істиною повною і якісною та
міцною зріжка освіти та науки України
долучався до нашого ефіру марафону
об'єднані новини